the final round of the 2019 u.s. Chess  Championships in st. Louis saw the  crowning of to deserving champions 24 of  the best players in the country meant  for the annual fight for the title as  king and queen of the United States in  the open section who was a close  struggle throughout til the final round  saw Aviano caruana and anair Dominguez  failed to keep pace with the brilliant  play of Hikaru Nakamura who won a  fantastic last round game to garner his  fifth US Championship title in the  women's section 17 year old Jennifer you  dazzled from start to finish with an  incredible 10 points out of 11 to win by  an amazing two and a half points and  also become the youngest winner in  almost twenty years it was a wild ride  with lots of thrills and spills and in  the end of brilliant finish to the  strongest national championship in  history